ela sofre muito mais um vídeo e hoje vou
ensinar como fazer um tanque de guerra
tem que haver certa atividade para com o
canhão e metralhadoras de elásticos
eu quando era pequeno que estava muito
brincalhão guerrinha de fazer os meus
próprios tanques porém nunca tinha
conseguido fazer um tanquinho cria
naquela altura e lembrando que só nos
dias atrás eu pensei bem seria muito
engraçado fazer esse projeto por
entender que utilizar os mesmos
materiais que tinha naquela altura como
molde uma bandeira política de lado é
cartão cola e outras coisas que vocês
vão ver ao longo do tutorial
a única dificuldade a esposa tem que
encontrar os motores por isso que eu
naquela altura o último tava tudo
tivesse motores e aguardava para fazer
os meus projetos
mas se vocês não tiverem casa podem
comprar online e se vocês forem crianças
peçam ajuda o do meu filho estrutural de
maneira tão simples que se eu tivesse a
ver o vídeo alguns anos atrás e
conseguiu fazer um projeto fácil - e vai
fazer uma pequena demonstração dos bons
cenários passo a passo então bora lá
[Música]
então vamos começar a primeira coisa que
você tem que fazer desenhar estão usando
um quadro que é muito mais fácil e
depois de cortar com muito cuidado
caso vocês sejam crianças peçam ajuda um
adulto que dessa forma vai ser muito
mais divertido e seguro para vocês
procurar uso de cola quente mas vocês
não tiverem esta podem usar outro
qualquer para fazer rodas vocês têm que
cruzar circus com três centímetros de
diâmetro e depois cláudio em pilha até
chegar uma altura de mais ou menos três
centros para jogos ficarem mais fortes
vocês têm que cortar uma faixa com três
centímetros de largura e depois pular à
volta desta forma casuística um pouco
desnivelado vocês têm que cortar os
testes usando uma tesoura faça um furo
no centro não precisam ter essa bancada
como tanque basta ter uma furadeira e no
total vão precisar de 8 rodrigues destas
se vocês quiserem podem usar tampas têm
de fazer isto agora vai precisar de um
tubo de caneta com 3,5 centímetros e
depois khullar pedaços do lápis a volta
que tem três centros de computar o circo
colocam cola deste lado e ponham um
circo com 35 pontos de ano
se vocês quiserem podem por um circo um
pouco maior se quiserem com quatro
centímetros de diâmetro que desta forma
vai segurar melhor as lagartas porque os
dois conseguem movimentar o tanque forma
eficiente vocês têm que rolar pedaços de
políticas de lado e entre outubro ou
seja naquela região um dos tubos se
conectam
para colocar os motores desses duas
aberturas retangulares porém os vossos
motores foram diferentes aberturas
também terão ser diferente na hora do
claro não sou um pouco de cola e coloca
o motor
esperem que segue quando vocês acharem
que estava vinculado então aí vocês
podem reforçar porque se enganarem assim
conseguem facilmente escolar e voltaram
claro tom de fixar o site de rodas eu
vou usar equipamentos do lado porém se
vocês não tiverem podem usar cartão
também células e vejam que as medidas
não vai ser contada direita para a
esquerda inclui começam 48 e depois dos
centros por colocar o terceiro antes dos
pleitos mais pequenos uma vez contou
está ali por baixo mas se o assunto for
de frente escolher aquela região vai
ficar livre podem pôr todos iguais
vou passar agora políticos de churrasco
para os furos e depois faltando ter mais
um excelente a frente que é só colocar
cola nesta parte que querem que segue na
posição certa e depois coloca em rodas
como disse anteriormente se vocês
quiserem podem usar rodas feitas com
tampas que é muito mais rápido e fazer
como eu não tinha as tampas é que eu
queria então acabei por fazer tudo de
cartão para que eles não saiam é só você
escolar em alguma coisa na extremidade
neste caso aqui usar equipamentos dê
lado de conca outro mais ligeiramente
mais para frente isso vai ajudar
contando consiga subir em obstáculos
mais facilmente
para isso basta colar dois políticos do
picolé nestas posições
acho que a distância entre o eixo e
aquela parte do tanque e dois
centímetros por fazer rodas com nossa
frente utilizados para definir lápis com
três centímetros um pedaço de tubo com
400 e quiserem podem cortar de uma
caneta e depois dois círculos com três
centímetros ou mais de diâmetro
vamos começar por colar a volta do
estudo de caneta
os pedaços do lápis e façam forma que
fique 0,5 centímetro do turno de um lado
e do outro a marca dentro do tubo no
centro do sossego e depois do tiro e com
muito cuidado o que quiser utilizar cola
e nesta parte espanhola só em cima dos
lábios
depois pedem que sempre conversei com o
faça o mesmo para o outro lado do oceano
e banho para marcar a partirem e colhem
neste lado muito tempo vocês deixaram o
tubo 10 908 para fora em ambos os lados
para fazer as lagartas e outras áreas
que carpete porém se vocês não tiverem
podem usar tecido ou então cortar uma
bexiga de bicicleta que tenha também
três centímetros de diâmetro com que a
roda que fiz anteriormente prende na
mesma maneira que o físico jogos cartão
fiquei qual é o melhor cumprimento para
as lagartas não pode ficar nem muito
apertado é muito soltos em uma eterna
depois que grupos mais ou menos 2
centers
como vocês podem ver que nesta partida
fizeram o exame ter sido então uma
câmera da área como vocês é de ensinar
alguma coisa por veicular para dar levar
legados desta forma bastante vai
conseguir subir os obstáculos mais
facilmente colocar as lagartas primeira
em cima e depois nos jogos de baixo e
agora vamos testar para ver seus motores
dando a mesma velocidade
o primeiro museu que eu fiz é o do outro
lado direito andava mais rápido comentou
do lado esquerdo
agora vamos sondar os cabos mas se vocês
não tiverem ferguson não tem problema
nenhum podem simplesmente roubar os
cabos e vai funcionar
uma coisa que vocês não podem deixar de
fazer é colocar fita cola para evitar
que haja curto circuito
para fazer a cabeça do tempo utilizado
desenhar este aqui ponham paulo a
conquistar no início e depois vão
circular neste projecto fazer tudo de
forma que vocês tenham que eu quero
fazer em casa ou seja em outro projeto
fazia tempo em que vocês tenham que
imprimir claríssima do cartão coar e já
estava feito o problema é que muitas
pessoas não conseguiram tirar da
internet mas não conseguiu tirar a
escala certa e outras pessoas não tenham
impressora então pensei bem
desta forma toda a gente vai conseguir
fazer dois pilotos grandes aqueles que
normalmente usa para terceira idéia
forma que vocês acabaram de ver uma
faixa de 3 centímetros por 20
centímetros de comprimento marca em nove
centímetros em uma partida com quatro
centímetros
vejam coloca a bola em duas partes ou
por agora este retângulo com três
centímetros por quatro centros e ali
naquela partida frente o suporte para os
elásticos o juca um fio passa naquela
parte da madeira e vai passar aqui pela
polícia do motor
este motor que gera muito devagar desta
forma os elásticos vão sendo aos poucos
sai 12
a gente sai outro porque se tornaram
muito rápido os relógios vão sair todos
muito muito rápido e você não vou
conseguir parar em vários alvos foi uma
hora aqui como podem carregar
para instalar a metralhadora fiz uma
abertura de cinco centímetros por cinco
centímetros
eu sei que parece um pouco foi agora mas
mais para frente eu vou colocar uma peça
do cartão que vai ter para tudo e vai
deixar seu espaço 112 lático saírem e
vejam que o empreendedor ocupa a base da
nossa cabeça temos comprimento é igual
ou seja esta parte cinzenta tem 20 de
comprimento e é baseado e também tem 20
centro
eu coloquei um bolso que vai ajudar a
gente tirar a montadora para fora
recarregar e voltar a instalar lá no
sítio certo para fazer o candal um sinal
de folhas tamanho a3 caso vocês não
tenham é só juntar duas folhas com
tamanha quatro são aquelas normais da
emissora passa uma rifa no final prendam
com fita cola para não ser lá por fazer
o câmbio vocês tentam juntar três folhas
tamanho a3 por isso é só usar uma cola
líquida normal sogro por uma folha a
outra em mais ou menos um centímetro um
centro em maio para espalhar a qual é o
uso do dedo porque se usar o pincel
sempre esqueça de limpar no final e
acabou por ser ilegal e roubo e depois a
folha a volta da rifa desta forma vamos
ter um diâmetro interno no tubo igual
dentro externo da rifa corta três
centros higuaín vai usar mais tarde
[Música]
e vou fazer um pistão da arma para isso
eo juntei quatro asiáticos porque os e
com bastante então para aumentar um
pouco a força
vou usar aqui um pedaço três cêntimos
que curtem a pouco do cano que eu disse
lá pra vocês guardarem para mais tarde
voltar aqui o chefe da fifa que passa
aquela parte do tubo por zelaya chegou
hoje a copenhague um nó e agora é só
prender usando fita cola
convém que fique bem apertado podem
passar várias vezes fita cola aqui vai
ficar este mesmo banheiro existente pode
ficar ainda mais resistente é só colocar
um pouco de super cola nesta região que
por colocar o carro na cabeça do tanque
curta e um pedaço de três centímetros
por 15 centímetros de campeão
conquistado e colar no lado esquerdo da
cabeça depois que cola só em deste
encontro do cano ou seja aquela parte
que não tem nenhum outro lado papel nem
cartão a volta por poder prender os
elásticos mais tarde com dois pedaços de
política de manter será nesta quarta à
frente da cabeça
se vocês quiserem podem pôr outra coisa
qualquer o importante é que consigo
explicar os elásticos
[Música]
para ativar a arma vão precisar de um
tocando muito lentamente e depois
prender um fio ao eixo outra parte do
fio sem prender ao projeto e depois não
podem colocar um pedaço de possível
comentou mais ou menos a mais do bolso
foi de cartão e tenham cuidado para não
colar as engrenagens do outro lado
prenda um tecido aparelho na cabeça
[Música]
e agora vamos ver como funciona a
primeira coisa que tem que fazer neste
car os elásticos e prendeu sob a frente
e esqueci de dizer mas tem que colocar
um público super cola na parte do cartão
compensado que estou encaixar agora o
pistão e depois é só dar energia autor e
isto diz para poder gerar a cabeça do
tanque e fiz uma polia quando centenas
na parte maior e 10 em tempos na parte
mais pequena luz e cartão compensado mas
se vocês quiserem podem usar o cartão
normal que também serve
só que este aqui é muito mais resistente
que o outro fez um buraco no centro com
tamanho em 14 ou seja 4 milímetros e
depois pula em cima diz pedaço de cartão
que tem 14 por 11,8 centímetros
não existem mais ou menos aproximado
vocês têm que ver como é que vai
encaixar melhor no vosso tanque
com terminarem decolar faz um buraco na
camada de cartão que está por baixo da
polónia
[Música]
portanto para que o buraco da cimpor
cinco centenas na partida contra a
cabeça do tam
vou colocar aqui um canto que vai ter um
sonho que na abertura para os elásticos
saírem desta forma vai esconder todas
aquelas coisas que dá pra ver por aqui o
furacão e para isso acontecer temos que
tirar essa parte com um x-ato agora como
vocês podem ver fica muito mais bonito
com isso aqui vai ficar preso vamos usar
de dois políticos um para encaixar em
cima e outro encaixar do lago
mas quando você se encaixar em um lado
convém que passa por baixo daquela
plataforma do cartão fizemos por a
mantenedora faça um furo no meio tanque
com 15 tentos da partida frente o futuro
tem que ser de 4 mil limpos como buraco
vocês fizeram para a poluir coloque um
palito que tem um diâmetro ligeiramente
nora e cole usando super cola quando
colocarem o planeta vou parar que vai
bater num western dólares sendo
propósito para vocês conseguirem desta
forma colar e ficar banheiro existente
nessa 1,5 centímetro da parte de trás do
tanque e depois faça um espaço para
colocar um motor está aqui também tem
que andar muito lentamente para assim
vocês conseguirem controlar facilmente a
rotação da cabeça um pouco de cola e
agora vamos instalar a cabeça no vasco
tem 3 1 utilizado um elástico grande se
vocês não tiverem um destinando bilhões
podem sempre juntar vários elástico é
ter uma dimensão de quatro vai instalar
um motor
devemos colocar no eixo e depois o
elástico vai ficar em cima do eixo do
motor e vamos fazer aquilo que o teste
para ver se funciona
podem ver gerou muito lugar perfeito
para conseguir acertar nos autos
[Música]
agora vou pular na bola no lado direito
e outro no lado esquerdo e vejam que
estas partes tem uma secção escavada
retangular momento
antes de começar a rolar é muito
importante colocar o planeta gelado já
na posição certa
hoje eu matei o centro do conflito e lá
vou colocar dois pedaços com dois
centímetros e depois vou colocar um ano
de um lado e outro do outro lado passam
quatro furos e uma tampa de garrafa
grande tenha atenção para eles ficarem
simétrico
ou seja o futuro de um lado tem que
responder o furo do outro lado também já
que passei e ramos pelos furos e depois
prendeu utilizando cola e vou colocar
também cola no meio da tampa pro
veicular aquela livre coca-cola essa
tampa tem um furo no centro que vai
permitir colocar um político que vai
servir de hess para este controle
vincular duas molas na parte de cima do
comando e com elas e vou te levar as
armas ou seja com uma mola vou te parar
o caminhão ficou outra mola vou te falar
a não levar muita atenção nesta parte
primeiro você tem que colocar o anel no
centro
depois de dizer que ela parte para baixo
e coloca em outra forma consideramos que
toca em 2 a 2 e vejam que tem dois anos
sem se machucar se os dois em baixo e
temos fazer a mesma coisa mas quando
utilizarem quilo para cima dessa forma
vocês vão conseguir sempre inverter a
popularidade e fazer o time andar para a
frente e para trás
tem que fazer a mesma coisa para o outro
lado para controlar a cotação da cabeça
vamos encaixar isso é que há um buraco
ficar 50 da base e vou fazer a mesma
coisa que fizemos do outro lado mas de
forma rotativa
primeiro em caixas maio depois das
visitas até tocar os 2 a 2
depois tem que fazer o mesmo mas para o
outro lado está a tocar um centro e
agora no lado esquerdo também
desta forma consegue controlar a direção
da cabeça tanto pela direita como pela
esquerda rodando a tampa
o circuito é muito simples você só tem
que conectar os pinos que estão no meio
assinalados a verde ao lado negativo de
pilha e o restante que sobrará ao lado
positivo
agora eu vou colar estarão aqui em cima
da bola e quando é movimentar a mola
orando vai tocar no circuito positivo
como vocês conseguem ver aqui nesta
parte
em seguida você tem que juntar os pinos
usando o cabo e se vocês não tiverem
ferguson não tem problema nenhum basta
você roubar os cabos como deve ser
no lado direito eu mando juntar os cabos
que vem do lado direito do time
vocês conseguem ver que já está a
funcionar e vocês têm que fazer o mesmo
para o outro lado para controlar a
cabeça vamos ligar os cabos esta parte
que central que tenha tampa para ativar
as armas apurado não interessa mais para
não ficar confuso basta vocês conectarem
o cabo verde ao cabo verde depois usou a
moral lá em cima tem que fazer a mesma
coisa para o outro motor vai juntar e
usou em cima e depois o verdão e nos
cabo verde
tem um software do fim os processos
executados projeto aqui se tiver alguma
sugestão de algum projeto é só deixar
nos comentários
no próximo vídeo vou trazer o sinai
porque o de ter trazido alguns dias
antes a ele sobre a triste du até a
próxima